[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
the following is a presentation of the
st. Louis chess club players from 14
nations converge in st. Louis as US
chess champs calm presents the third
annual spring chess classic and welcome
back to the 2019 spring chest classic my
name is Caleb Dundee here filling in for
Ben Simon
as always I'm joined by am on Hamilton
doing commentary over today's games in
round eight of the chess classic so
let's take a look at our standings
actually going into you know the eighth
round
let's see everybody where everybody
stacks up of course there's Jeffrey
Zhang and iliyan is Nick in a tie for
first
after Jeffrey drew his game yesterday
and Ilya pulled out a win in a rook end
game against Eric Hanson and that was
actually the only decisive result of the
game yesterday yeah it's kind of
surprising we've actually had a number
of rounds where every game has even been
drawn and we've experienced some big
pile ups at the top of the table for
that first place pot but now ninja Nick
sort of puts his name in the Hat as
we're wrapping up the tournament
tomorrow and all of a sudden he's at the
top of the table absolutely re ontari in
reg Robson are actually both still
within striking distance so if they have
a couple good games going into these
final rounds we might see them come from
behind - you know when the event
definitely no anyone can win at this
point moving on to group B let's see who
we've got up near the top we've got by
Jun Jie still pulling far ahead with
five and a half out of seven everybody
else you know still seemingly you know
left in the dust
ya know by Jin she is made a statement
earlier in the tournament with a lot of
wins in row and then now it seems that
he can almost just draw I mean he or
finished his game today for example so
he's up to six points and barring
another player winning the last two
games in a row or maybe a disaster for
him in the final round he does look like
the front-runner to win the the B group
absolutely I guess we'll have to see
today if Parrish bullets can pull off a
couple nice wins to try and close that
gap
moving on let's see what kind of format
the players are playing in in these two
tournaments or two events rather there
are two ten player round robins actually
the time control for both is of course
90 minutes for 40 moves with the classic
30-second increment starting from move
one at move 40 the players actually do
receive an extra 30 minutes to finish
out the game as always there's also the
30 move draw roll in effect so there
will be no drawers before I move 30
unless of course we see a repetition of
moves
moving on of course you guys are always
welcome to watch this live on youtube I
think we've got the YouTube chat pulled
up here it's good to see you guys in
here Tommy Leblanc I saw viola player in
there as well Miguel Rodriguez the
comments are flowing okay nice keep them
coming guys good to see you guys also
the games are live on us chess champs
calm if you want to follow along and
play through the moves yourself now
let's actually take a look at the
pairings for today so in Group A of
course we have Benjamin Bach playing in
sorry ontari Rey Robson against vara
Cobian Iligan is Nick was paired against
laQuan Liam we've got Ivanchuk against
Eric Hanson and finally our key matchup
of the day we've got Roose Tom Kasim
jonov playing Jeffrey Zhang of course
Roose Tom is struggling a bit this
tournament not managing to find any wins
and Jeffrey of course in a tie for the
lead so it's my speed this might be a
decent chance for Jeffrey to pull ahead
of Illya yeah it's a it's a weird
feeling sometimes when you play these
close tournaments because sometimes in
the final rounds it's not like a Swiss
where you're playing someone who may be
fighting for first place with you you
could be playing the guy in last place
so although we see a mismatch maybe
about how the players are doing in the
tournament I don't think the chasm Jonah
he may be actually one of the more
unpredictable opponents could be tough
for Jeffrey here yeah a veteran in the
chess scene for sure
and let's actually take a look at their
game and see how they're doing
yeah we got this this game up here you
can see the players on the screen
already I mean Kasim Joe no sipping that
tee I'm a little nervous if I'm Jeffrey
he looks Kasim jonov looks like a guy
who has nothing to lose look very stoic
right so look at the board right we can
jump to the beginning of this game and I
sort of see what what happened and how
we got here as Kasim jonov and Geoffrey
elected to go into a little bit of
theory and this has all been more or
less played before this idea of Queen b6
white reacts with a3 and Geoffrey is
probably smart enough not to go grab
this guy be to the classic Queen trap
right you know this is times when I
really miss Bensimon on it is cuz I
could really get Ben to fall into the
trash you have to take that part where
can't you can't you play doll nah you've
got me there
exactly exactly we miss you Ben so this
is the whole idea you play a3 and it's
it's kind of nicer than than any of
these other weird moves to defend the
pawn so a3 is quite a useful move 97 and
pretty quickly we actually saw Bruce
Timm clarify the center with with f5 and
you know generally black doesn't want to
take and give up the d5 square and sort
of give these these pieces for white
really easy access to the positions so
kind of a more of a forcing sequence and
from here I think we can kind of
envision blacks set up a little bit
maybe rook c8 maybe in the future he
castles but I don't know if I would be
brave enough what about you if white was
counseling this way do you have the the
guts to Castle kingside when that pawn
store might be coming up the board got
it playa I'm liking the e8 Square from
my King at the moment right right maybe
stay in the center the idea in all these
positions for white is always to try to
stick a piece on d5 right so how close
is white to actually achieving something
like that here right yeah if I mean if
this night for example vacates you
always have that idea of of taking here
and even if the bishops on e7 you can do
a similar idea try to use that square
but really ideal for white is is
is uh you know if somehow we can trade
these LightSquared bishop skating
control the d5 square like you mentioned
right but yeah it's it's still quite a
struggle because you never want to be
taking back with a pawn and for the
moment it looks like he's gonna have to
work a little bit harder to to achieve
that three and we sort of see blacks
position developing as we expect it and
this g4 move is the type to really scare
you away from castling kingside
absolutely castling queenside though is
it's not any better as we see blacks
queen side is also completely exposed
here so as you mentioned King on e8
might be the safest place for it despite
despite all the advice we get to always
Castle 95 and this was yeah this h4 move
the Queen I don't have three guards the
rook on each one so there really are
ideas like just very quickly g5 and then
either g6 or f6 coming up next and
Jeffrey's looking at position where he's
still actually struggling to not only
complete his development but you know
that King we keep mentioning that might
have to stay in the middle of the board
it's not too comfortable yeah and the
center seems to be fairly close to
opening right you know the open D file
certainly not not helping the king and
the e pawn kind of the last defender
keeping that King safe ya know that
that's a hero right there without the e
pawns on the board I think black would
be in serious trouble and I think we're
catching up to the current position here
after Queen c7 93 and 97 and I believe
that this is the position on the board
maybe one more move by Bruce time he
just played the move B 3 so b3 played
maybe he was a little concerned about b3
by black sort of prying open the Queen
side a little bit and using the pressure
on the C file but I'm sort of wondering
does does Bruce Timm have a breakthrough
here or as black actually going to get
away with leaving his King that in the
middle for so long I also have some
questions about the move Knight c5 from
black here is this playable because I'm
not so sure you know you know I guess
you know blood white would have to play
King b1 yeah and probably King b1 there
anyway for black to try to break through
before
white even has time to ring said yeah if
I grab this we do have to take with the
Queen to guard that pawn in situ and I
don't know if that's necessarily the
best move but I mean black always has
also this this a5 a4 and we could even
do that I'm here as well
Bishop b5 checks maybe something I don't
want to allow but I do feel like we got
to address this maybe soon as a beep on
could be taken as white I'm thinking
about moves like G 5 f6 all this kind of
stuff really making sure that that this
King doesn't feel comfortable in the
center absolutely
but yeah I think I think 95 is a very
reasonable move the other movement maybe
comes to mind for most of us as well
maybe I just develop my bishop because
I'm I'm supposed to have that right now
is what does it move 22 and black is
still not fully developed so I think the
move Bishop c5 or and 95 come to mind
here for black and what about the e7
score for the bishop maybe trying to
stave off g5 for a while longer right
bit should be 7 and then you even have
the c5 square for the knight so sort of
keep keep both of those ideas in the air
and I think maybe amongst all these
moves there's also Queen a5 which I mean
this King might feel a little bit area
on the dark squares here it's Queen a1
queen a3 start to become threats so it
does feel like there's a lot of action
around White's King but again you have
to remember that blacks sort of playing
without his rook on honey right so and
g5 is coming quite soon too right
take advantage of that H file in that
King stuck kind of dividing the black
pieces exactly so it just looks like all
the ideas seem to be there for for black
like 95 Queen a5 we we see the potential
white doesn't have many you know
concrete attacking ideas there's no
tactics really but he is just have this
slow plan of g5f 6 maybe g5 g 6 as well
try to open up the light squares and
long term I mean he's fully developed
and it seems like maybe white has the
better position let's say but very very
tricky to play especially with this king
with all these moves and mines do you
think b3 was actually required from
white it seems like a you know class
and a move to slow down black's pawn
storm but to my eyes c3 doesn't or b3
doesn't seem the most dangerous after
white could play move like c3 right let
the c3 after B through that black you
mean C yeah yeah so I know III think
that b3 was was he's trying to say maybe
that after b3 king b1 that there's like
nothing yeah I think he's trying to say
this is the end of of the attack
although 95 Queen a5 looked good
with a king on b1 you're always ready to
take that bishop back with your queen
and maybe that buys him the time that he
needs to to get these Kings side moves
so understandable don't know if it
actually was necessary but it seems like
that is gonna be his plan if he's gonna
remain consistent here and stick to the
b3 move so that's probably what he's
intending King b1 looks like a move I
play next even if I didn't wasn't
provoked and then just getting those
King side pawns rolling in and we see
the time there Geoffrey is now thinking
26 minutes roost M has just under 15 and
the players as we mentioned move 22 so
actually they're not that close to
report II might see some time some time
pressure here some moves to go yeah
alright with that in mind why don't we
take a look at the pairings and Group B
for this round and see what we've got
going on over there looks like we've got
hidin Stein Grimson paired against
Christian trilha I got Sergey Arenberg
playing Nicholas Theodore ooh by Shinji
was against Dennis Catterick as we said
you know that game is already ended in a
draw Gregory Caetano is playing Alexi
Sorkin and of course bearish bullets
it's playing Alexander Mesa and this is
gonna be our key matchup for the day
actually so let's see if bearish bullets
can pull anything off against Mesa to
try and close that gap between him and
by janeshia yeah baarish bullets as well
you can see there he's undefeated in the
tournament so far and and there's not
many players who are so that's a very
solid result for him he's sitting on
that plus to score and late in the
tournament this is actually matchup
between two people who very close to the
top of the table and very hydrated in a
big group absolutely
so let's take a look and see what's
going on on the board here we are there
are the players there you can see
on the cam and offhand it looks like
this is one of those positions which is
completely different from the one we
just looked at you know we had all the
pieces on in almost the opening position
right in chasm John Hobbs game and then
suddenly we go here and we're looking at
a game that's nearly wrapping up and
trading towards an end game oh yeah so
both players seem to have the the two
bishops the obviously the the standout
piece is the e7 pawn right and that's
gonna be pretty much the decider right
if white is better or if Y does worse
that's gonna depend on whether or not he
can keep that pawn around yeah I think
it's got a limited life expectancy here
I mean King f7 and I already don't see
how we keep the pond unfortunately for
white this Bishop just doesn't seem to
be able to enter the action anywhere
whether it's on c4 on this diagonal and
the b v square is also covered so
black's pawn structure is actually
perfect against this light square bishop
I don't have time to sort of sneak
around it's no way for me to keep that
pawn directly yeah one line that I've
noticed it's White's turns so if you
know Rick to d7 would be played of
course the black bishop wouldn't really
want to vacate that diagonal that the
King sets on or else you know Bishop f7
might come right well sorry Bishop c4
preventing king f7 might come right but
if you do see a move like Bishop e6 or
something then that leaves the b-pawn
behind right so to my is it looks like
the black bishop might be kind of kind
of stuck between you know two jobs
that's trying to carry out well the nice
thing and probably the savior for black
here is that in this position it
actually is his move so he's just played
the move king of seven oh okay and then
and suddenly but that actually means
that really the whole evaluation comes
down to that one tempo because right had
it been White's move you're exactly
right that play broke d7 all of a sudden
I have to choose between a pawn and this
Bishop c4 move and suddenly my King
might never access the e pawn totally I
think it just came down to that that
calculation there but misto seems to be
in time with king f7 now the
the rook the rook d7 move is still
something I would I would give serious
thought to yeah at first glance I
thought that might just be met with
takes on e7 right and then tactically
does does that work out for for black
well first of all Bishop takes e7 and
then nicely we got this check here so
we're not dropping our next piece and if
let's say rook takes d5 Bishop takes b4
and although we've got opposite bishops
here I think it's pretty clear that
black has a push he's got an outside
pass pawn potential and I mean no doubt
he's gonna play it on for for quite a
while yeah and it's kind of unclear if
White has any choice but to go for this
end game because right that pawn is not
long for this earth no 37 is is probably
on his mind here but I think he knows
he's gonna be suffering some some sort
of endgame you just got to pick which
one you want absolutely 7 is there any
way to play a Bishop c4 and is there a
better drawing chance in the Solrock
endgame where the the bishops aren't
actually on the board yeah it feels like
Bishop c4 is a serious candidate first
of all if I take here
rook c7 may be appetizing but I think
that if I move this this king we run
into the fact that once again there's a
discovered check there so right
something like I don't know King King f6
and if we take again that's gonna be a
check to White's King hitting the rook
and if we don't try to grab this then we
were falling to check here yeah just uh
what happens on Bishop c3 for example
for white maybe and then trying to pick
up this pawn mm-hmm and then well yeah
okay if I give Shaq it's gonna be close
you're gonna go run yeah Bishop here it
looks like I'm gonna end up pinned right
but maybe I can survive this somehow so
then we got this endgame and the
question is sort of as this one winning
I have a feeling that that it might be
as black can sort of play King up here
and we
one move to waste maybe maybe if I get F
4 F 3 here it's a lot of counting that's
a lot of counting not sure if I'm
prepared to do it well let these guys
we'll let these guys calculate that
absolutely but I think that's the type
of line that's really scary to be
looking at if you're white where yeah
Mike it's all component it yeah it's
that yeah that's the way you lose
dealing in absolutes as always scary in
chess these are highly commendable
decisions but maybe he could try to do
that position and just not take the pawn
on b7 play rook endgame down upon yeah
that's another option from there
maybe he's the first thing though it's
really hard for a chess player is you
have to admit that you can play a pawn
down right and that's a pretty big
decision sometimes you might try to hang
on in the pond too much and that's even
worse you should just let it go and find
the best drawing endgame and he's gonna
decide whether he can liquidate some
bishops here or you know which one he
sort of wants to play alright so we'll
let Andrew I think on that and let's
take a look and see what these players
at the top are actually playing for
we've got a fairly large prize fund
actually for these two groups first
place in the a group is actually walking
away with $6,000 which is a full $2,000
ahead of second so of course Jeffrey and
Ilya are not gonna be willing to let
that mm no quite so easily on of course
everybody walks away with something and
you know 7th through 10th all actually
go home with $1,000 themselves so not
too bad not too bad oh man and over in
the B group let's take a look
looks like first place gets $4,000 in
the B group so of course that's looking
looking good for bhaijan sheep but we'll
see if you know of course spirit bullets
can hold this end game and then I think
actually that would knock him almost
fully out of contention for first place
right no I think by June she you know
but barring his his potential loss
tomorrow
I mean players really do need to win two
games in a row and bars bullets is the
closest to him actually yes so it's it's
gonna be tough for anyone to be able to
catch him there but
i s let's just go around the boards and
see if anything interesting is is going
on yeah we got some like we've been
mentioning we have a few results I mean
already in the B group one game that
looks like some action has happened
really early was between the Hayden
Stein crimson and Christian korilla and
the reason I say that is because it
looked like they were actually going
through some theory in in that game but
then all of a sudden I I just noticed
that Carrillo was missing a C pawn and I
wasn't too sure if this was theory or or
if maybe he have confused theory in his
head or something cuz Bishop a3 going to
take this pawn and I noticed this
position he just took it he just grabbed
the pawn we were actually taking a look
at this game but before the show started
and just looking at the body language of
both players Hyden seems almost confused
at the position he's gotten you know
he's both players kind of fidgety I
think Christian you know what went for
the T a couple times right he's loading
up with a caffeine maybe to prepare for
this this position yeah but so yeah just
down the C pawn but it looked to my eyes
like there is some tactical waste that
you know black might be able to regain
that later on well I think based on the
time situation I can sort of infer that
nobody at this chess board has any clue
what's going on because Christian is
down in ten minutes yeah and they're on
move 15 likes it they actually have so
many moves to make until time control
and you know maybe this started off as
something that people knew but sometimes
it's really easy to confuse lines in
your head and think oh it was usually a
line where I can sack this pawn and
maybe he thought it was but Steingarten
is sort of calling him out on the
potential Bluff right he says I'm just
gonna grab that pawn and show me where
the compensation is yeah it's it's tough
to see immediately but how did the game
continue it was B six then a six just
sort of kicking these bishops back black
always has this idea of like long term I
can play a five yeah a five and pawn on
c3 might end up hanging right this is
this is what I was trying to figure out
right so he's played to move a six and
it was met with Queenie
now that's sort of telling me that maybe
the movie 5 would also be met with Queen
a4 right I don't know that if that would
be the reaction but something like here
a5 I mean Bishop a3 sort of runs into
exactly what black is looking for that
that tactic but maybe Queen a4 here and
it's possible that something just as
simple as this guerrilla thought oh that
can't be taken because I've BB 685
winning the bishop but me as Queen a4
move was was kind of overlooked yes but
you know queen i for did happen on the
board after a six right sure didn't
after Bishop d7 isn't white faced with
some of the same problems right yep no
here he played the move Bishop d3 I have
to wonder in this position whether a5
was was on his mind or not because if I
was definitely consideration although
now it's a little bit different that you
you do defend that rook from h1 rights
and then the rope swings over to c1 and
I'm actually not too embarrassed with my
King on e to it's actually kind of
strong right uh this is actually a line
I was looking at and here I thought you
know maybe black might be able to play
something like Bishop you know c6 mm-hmm
and then I guess you know Queen c4 is an
option but you know the line I was
thinking of my might be Queen b3 and I
thought that looked line for black after
after the captures let's say here I
wasn't sure how to evaluate this this
pawn structure mm-hmm
offhand I would say that looks really
annoying for black how do I deal with
this pond right because if I if I Castle
I mean we know Sanger was in he's
already taken upon he's gonna grab
another one he's in the mood today so it
looks like it's tough to Castle and if I
play east six then it's actually very
tough yeah
and I got some moves coming with tempo
like rook c1 maybe be four to open
things up so if I could castle here I
would probably agree but I feel like the
pressure on e7 is actually more annoying
because it's looks like white on clear
but yes that's so easy to regain the
pawn then no not at all and and not like
gorillas uncomfortable playing down upon
because often in the grin felt you do
have those positions where you even sack
an exchange or salon but maybe that
wasn't his intention going into the game
and then you sort of have to adjust so
this is us getting closer and closer to
current position the
have made a few moves in the meantime
just as you know I was mentioning he's
down there like 10 minutes apiece so
these guys needs to speed up and kind of
a familiar structure here where you know
Black has the the bishops aimed at
White's Center but White has the two
strong center pawns but right I wish I
could say this was familiar but the only
thing that's unfamiliar is like hey yeah
where's my you mother it used to be on
e7 and suddenly I feel like if the pawn
was on e7 that this should be around
even right but if there's just a pawn
missing then this has to be seriously in
whites favor here it's it's tough to
tell you know just what black is you
know supposed to even do here it seems
as though none of his pieces can really
move besides maybe you know bringing the
knight to f6 could be the next idea but
ya know I think I think he's definitely
gonna be considering with like Knight f6
he would love to to get white to play e5
and maybe sink the knight on d5 I mean
right here you can really can't castle
unless you play Bishop f8 is black so
it's it's not looking good though it
looks like an easy position for white to
play Bishop d3 king D to all look like
great moves not only is it a healthy
extra pawn but it's a center pawn yeah
and not looking good a little bit of a
time advantage as well like you were
mentioning but you know he's also
actually now down to 12 minutes himself
so yeah I think it's probably best case
for korilla here because if you're just
gonna be down upon looking for
compensation at least get some time
pressure a nice little you know put you
both under pressure and sort of mess
things up hope there's hope for some
mistakes right hope for some mistakes I
mean let's not forget Carrillo survived
down a rook yesterday yes doughnuts an
entire rope for a pawn seemingly
magically seemingly magic so so I'm not
gonna sit here and say that this one
pawn advantage is enough to topple him
because I've seen I've seen what he's
capable of so we'll have to see if Stein
Grimson can sort of convert this because
it does look to me like this is a
serious advantage for him here all right
moving on I think something about Sora
can might have might have made a blunder
in his game as let's try and find that
one here
let's take a look he's playing Gregory
Caetano of here and he's got the black
pieces Sorokin by the way for those that
remember early on he actually lost his
first two games in this tournament right
at the bottom of the table then all of a
sudden he flipped the entire tournament
around and I don't think he's lost since
so Alexi Sorokin is definitely a guy to
watch and as we get into these round
eight and round nine matchups I don't
know if he's gonna be feeling more
pressure but I mean he's got that GM
title that he's trying to go for and not
only is this a placement tournament for
him but this is a norm tournament
absolutely serious chances to you know
get that that next norm for him I'm not
sure if he's actually one normal way or
a few but I believe he's one one normal
voice I believe he could be this could
be huge for him if he manages to pull
out a win in these last couple of rounds
yeah he might might just get there no
he's already got the rating obviously
he's sitting way above 2,500 right now
as he competes in this tournament so it
really is just the norms for him is he's
got the f-m title and he's looking at it
looking to do some hop skip and jumping
absolutely so what I think this one I
mean I'm inclined to say that it's like
a grünfeld but I don't have no idea how
it started it's such a weird position a
double fianchetto yeah not really a
grünfeld at all but black sort of is
playing like it is a grin fell right you
got that deep on up the boarding you let
white take and you don't take back with
a pawn rather you capture with a piece
usually of course it's that knight on f6
but Queen takes on d5 kind of unorthodox
and queen h5 he's just going for the the
quick cheese right this is basically
Knight g4 take advantage of that those
those weaken light squares very common
idea it almost looks like you you know
this is an ID you see often you know
that white would play against black you
know and something right but the Pyrrhic
or something similar where right away
before you know the other player even
castles this attack is already starting
yeah and with we know in Age 5 I mean
sometimes you'll see the the Queen let's
say on d7 and the bishop on e6 and then
you're threatening Bishop h3 and then if
white plays h3 himself he can't castle
because you're sort of hitting that pawn
right in these situations it's a little
bit different because after h3 I always
have the move g4 which hits the Queen
and I can maybe castle with tempo but
I'm used to seeing Queen Age
a lot more once I'm already Castle
because there's nothing I can do about
Bishop age three it seems like blacks
using the extra time he made by not
moving the seat pone or the e pond you
know kind of launch this attack ya know
this is really quick play by Sorokin and
Caetano does plate three doesn't want
any part of Bishop h3 developing with
tempo rook d8 and it's just such an
unorthodox position that Sorokin is
getting already you don't see very often
just almost no pawns being used as
bayonets in the inner or to control the
center at all purely piece plays seems
you're white as well I mean just nobody
is putting pawns in the center so I
think finally after a few moves here
Caetano says look it's time to control
the center but you know this is actually
one of the weirdest opening phases I've
seen we're done no one is committing
yeah just you know trying to stay
flexible I guess is yes something both
players clearly value a lot in this line
yeah yeah Queen two beef I mean I think
at some point once your Bishop gets
kicked out of here you sort of give up
the dream of right of anything on h3 so
that Queen I think it was time for it to
move h5 just you almost risk getting
trapped in some lines didn't you stay
over there
so finally d4 and there's some pressure
here I mean these are all looking more
and more like backward pawns I mean it's
tough to get a e5 in if you play your be
pawn up and all of a sudden this rook
looks really good right
yes d5 it would have been nice rib like
if he could have gotten e5 before white
played d4 so maybe it's right it's maybe
weighted slightly too long alright
playing around with this pieces ya know
that's the thing you got this Queen here
you almost don't want to lock it out
right of all the action but it's just
there's so many things that that black
has in his position that are a little
bit unorthodox it's hard to hard to play
absolute or --ml moves yeah this is not
normal
but somehow actually Sorokin spieces are
all kind of defending each other so he's
going for this weird construction like
rook d6 Queen b5 Bishop on f7 and just
trying to say that he's watching over
all the key squares it's it's almost
tough to be mad with with a knight on d5
you know that
something like strikes quite a lot of
openings that's a strong piece now this
rook is doing heavy duty guarding that
knight on c6 very important but I get
the feeling that long term this queen is
going to vacate the e4 square and then
maybe we'll see efore by white so
something like Queen back to b1 c2 even
d3 and just be for maybe d5 e5 yeah my
only news piece my only concern for
white here would be that night on a4 I
guess it's coming to be too and maybe to
c4 to knock that rook around or d3 right
getting some time here but yeah that's
probably the only piece that white can
be critical of right his position as we
catch up to the game it was actually
this move e5 played by Sorokin so we
were talking about finding time for this
move he says there is time and the time
is now that pin on the d4 pawn is why I
down I've played rook c4 because
actually he simply just couldn't take
that right away
Queen a3 of course now you take it I
mean that's that just makes sense yeah
but that's rook e8 oh oh this is where
things actually got really forcing and
the players have actually come up with a
few more moves on the board here we can
take a look at those it was rook e8
pinning the pawn queen b1 getting out of
the pin absolutely and then b55 I think
at this point there there might be some
other issues with the position that I'm
curious what they are one thing that
comes to mind is that once this Knight
moves for example takes this pawn I have
to be really careful about either Bishop
takes d5 or just e 4 and this e7 pawn is
hanging where I end up a lot of lines so
maybe it's not so easy to take that pawn
back and something like pawn takes d5
might not be something like 1 0 right
because yes something like an 85 here
already way too many squares too many
squares it looks like so I think that b5
strikes me as one of those moves that
you play when maybe you missed something
in the line or to have to bail out it
looks complicated but I feel like it
shouldn't be justified at the very least
we see the continuation in the game it
was takes on d6 takes on c4 b takes c4
and black actually just played the move
Knight d2 b4 if he took the night there
white was gonna capture in the middle
and don't forget a flea all these
captures it's gonna still be whites
turns right they keep taking everything
everything everything but night before
was the move played and this is actually
our current position here as tie-down of
is a little bit lower on the clock here
but it's it's his move and things should
be in his favor I think I think he's
just got to do a bit of a bit of
calculation here the very least seems
like maybe he emerges a pawn and the
worst
I guess the current material count is
two pawns up for white but of course you
have to deal with this not in a four
which is under attack and then you know
maybe the d6 Punggol fall looks like at
the very least white might be able to
play something like Queen b3 just to
liquidate off you know blacks active
pieces and go for a pulling up endgame
but maybe he's trying to find better
yeah Queen b3 is a nice kind of move
because if I take and then we take back
on d6 again we are one pawn up there and
there's nothing wrong with any of our
pieces at that point he's actually gone
for the d7 just a little in-between move
there probably rook d8 I mean just just
has to be played and I mean is he
thinking about ideas like keeping that
pawn on on d7 trying to decide what what
he's going for here Queen b3 could also
be another way just different boria
trying to do that exact same thing but
one thing about Queen b3 that I liked
earlier was that Queen a2 wasn't really
possible because I might take and then
take that pawn on c7 right now tough for
black now that's a little different I
mean this pawn here maybe I lose that
and I've also lost my pawn in a - I
don't want to get in the 8th or we can
start to run but just out of curiosity
after Knight c5 it looks like black
already has to take some drastic
measures right right here III for white
here okay five yes I'm like maybe
something like Knight see to my dart II
have to be played in order to try to you
know get rid of this night in d7 pawn in
turn mm-hmm but then you know I was
starting to go maybe a little bit crazy
and I was thinking of something like
Queen B 5 for white trying to the sack
the exchange to keep that pawn on the
board right well the the other kind of
position that
I mean I'm considering even being greedy
here and in taking this I'm wondering if
I can get away with oh wow
can he get away with something as
ridiculous as this because this is
actually 100% on the board 95 by akadama
of and Sorokin is gonna have to come up
with some sort of funny business because
this pawn is is really strong here and
we we start to feel the pressure of this
Bishop on c6 yeah I gotta tell you I
don't have a lot of faith between takes
a to know by maybe maybe it holds right
right 92 it's surely gonna be on his
mind these kind of anything to get rid
of that Knight and sort of round up that
pawn on d7 because the longer you leave
that pawn there the more that white is
just gonna shift the rook over protect
it and there's ideas like Knight d7 and
whites play is actually fairly
straightforward so academic I think here
very happy with his position as they're
approaching move 30 and he's got about
nine minutes but when you've got the
better position you're hoping that the
moves come a little bit easier right
absolutely
as always the YouTube chat is interested
in Eric Hanson's games so I guess we can
take a look see what's going on there
sure he's playing Vasili Ivana
did they yeah the third game actually
looked very very even when I last saw it
which was sort of around here and we had
a Queens gambit declined where you know
all four of these pawns at some moment
just captured each other absolutely and
I think the key move for Eric in this
game probably the the move that after
this I think it's just very equal is
after 94 he played them with a 5 and I
think this a five move is really
important it gives up some squares here
but more importantly it secures this
knight on c5 from any b4 and I think
that would be the only way to maybe
jeopardize your position here of course
it and so yeah with no way to take
advantage of the open files
I guess we're probably gonna see some
major piece trades yeah pretty soon yeah
once you secure those two lanes you just
move them out of the way and it's like
look at all the firepower there you go
that's hidden behind there and trade all
the rooks I mean blacks queen is
defending all the weak pawns so this
check
doesn't mean anything of course and yeah
no way it's a really push for other
sites they'll just symmetrical pawns
symmetrical pieces yep
yeah and that's another game in the bag
for Yvonne Chuck where you know no
chance is really for for a win he's also
winless in this a group here as you know
no one's giving away easy points right
absolutely very tough competitors this
year right so I think the in the a group
that's the the second look Longley am an
initiative drew now Hanson and Yvonne
Jacque drew and the other game that I
thought was one to keep an eye on was
Ray Robson and Varco bein up in that a
group and that game we can see here is
is really spicy already a lot of you
know cover missing for that black King
which is in the center of the board this
looks like another trademark Varco being
fresh defense absolutely you know no
fear no fear for fire he's he scored
some wins and some good games actually
in the French so far this tournament so
it's really been working and also the
black pieces have done notoriously well
it's not like White's just winning all
these way Black has had a lot of upsets
it's very crazy position to my eyes I
guess you know black is kind of forsaken
castling by a you know playing this h6
g5 pawn break to try to open up White's
King he's kind of you know left his King
without a home as well but how did we
get here this this is just the move I
wanted to show in the opening which sort
of clarifies the pawn structure and how
we got here is this move f5 it's it's a
full pawn it's a free pond and bars
gonna take that you really can't let the
guy play f5 and then take on e6 you may
as well grab a pawn if you're going to
be suffering and they're being attacked
and the idea is is more of a positional
approach it's not sometimes you
sacrifice you get the piece pawn right
back right sometimes it's more of a
positional long-term thing and that's
what we see here
I think this position may strike a lot
of people as very good for black like
after Bishop e6 we sort of plug the hole
in the position and we just say like
I've got all my pawns and you know where
it where's the big attack I'd be
inclined to agree you know Black has
found squares for all of his pieces they
all seem to be you know working together
but Wyatt I really is just missing the
pawn too
to breakthrough I think yeah no it's
you're giving it away so you can use
these dark squares more effectively with
with your Bishop and queen and sort of
reroute these pieces but it's just kind
of interesting saying that you can't
Castle kingside
and if you cancel Queen side I'm also
going to open the position there and
meanwhile it's very difficult for black
to ever dream of h6 g5 because suddenly
your F pawn is very weak and you know
White's sort of on the offensive here
right so it really is the sort of
long-term sack that I have a feeling Ray
has sort of been over before it's not
something that he came up with at the
board understandable so we see white
trying to play in the dark squares here
and black opening up on the Queen side
of the board again these positions
always feel so good for black but then
the bottom line is once the position
opens up you got a king sitting on a e8
and you got some dark square holes and
that those can often just you know come
back to bite you he's opening up
everybody's no fear yeah and this is a
type of move d5 that I mean you almost
just have to play if Black gets some
sort of hold on the d5 square right and
then it's these pawns this is a move
that without calculation I would expect
a rate of play understandable so yeah
how does you know how does vara intend
to survive this cuz you know he's down
to mere seconds on his clock right so we
actually saw g5 Queen c1 and then the
move King the brave move King even and
this is actually our current position
here 31 var has I mean quite literally
he played that move with two seconds on
his clock connecting the rooks at all
costs yeah and looking at the players on
the camera there it looks like he's got
some nervousness he's working on there
ya know raised almost looking at this
position surgically he's wondering okay
where's the where's the end of this I
mean let's just point out the the rather
unfortunate H takes g5 would would
really hurt White's position here so
that pawn is definitely off-limits even
though it's it looks like we can win the
pawn there so ray can't be doing that
but at the same time if we count the
pawns I mean everyone technically one
pawn ahead here for for VAR I mean I
have have some dreams of just trading
some pieces bishops rooks and trying to
get out of this but with a time
advantage and blacks King rate in the
the board I have to feel like raids
doing well yeah and I'm just looking at
crazy ideas
so Knight takes d5 doesn't work here for
example but maybe if we play a bishop
takes six then a pawn takes c6 maybe and
right rook d6 as there's some ideas of
trying to you know break through with
Knight takes g5 now yeah we we have this
idea to try to break through I would be
equally careful of black coming maybe
with like a counter idea like 95 of
course in all of a sudden there's
actually two things hanging + and Knight
takes here or maybe even Knight g4 could
be scary in the right move order yeah of
course this would be this would be
terrible but I think raised is looking
for a knock up but the way that he's
hovering over that boy he's he's
scanning for four knockouts it's ready
for it I need the finds whatever his I
know it feels like there should be
something here right it certainly does
the other thing is that when the guys
got 32 seconds sometimes and maybe this
is unhealthy the chess players mind will
wander and not calculate maybe the best
move but the most tricky absolutely the
most tricky move because you just think
there's no way you can see all this
stuff with with 32 seconds but I've got
twenty minutes and I can't see all this
it's exactly so he yep and we see I
think some moves on the board as you can
see the players writing down some moves
that was Bishop takes c6 pawn takes c6
and I mean there's there's a lot of
things to consider here Knight takes g5
even here not sure if this is it's good
but there's definitely potential for
right having that really just stuck on
on h8 and and bring that rook into d6
yeah maybe here King e8 would be forced
because of King f8 you have this Queen
f6 idea and they're a rook lifts might
come if you try to defend your your rook
mm-hmm yeah no this this looks fun but
probably unnecessary honestly as we see
a move on the board Queen c4 there by
Rey and he sort of he didn't just play
one move he planned one move and then a
response and that's that's that's what
you're supposed to do when it guys in
time pressure is you don't play move
have him react and then let him think
again he was you did the right thing
he's got to move ready and far has got
to be down two seconds there on the
clock as he he's got to really really
find some some good moves here
because what are they on move 33 seven
tough moves it's so hard not to panic
when you find yourself in a situation
like this yeah do you want actually take
a look at Jeffrey Zhang's game again it
looks like some moves been played there
and Bruce Tom is actually in some
serious time pressure as well yeah time
pressure is probably going to be flying
in for all of these players here as we
jump to another very important game in
the a group for the standings as Jeffrey
Zhang is I mean he needs a draw to
maintain the lead along with iliyan is
Nick but win would catapult him and had
an absolutely very good standing going
into the final round it's a lot to play
for here we looked at this position
ready to start of the show this was our
key matchup and I think what sort of
developed after this move b3 was Bishop
to c5 and a quick f6 by roost and he
wants to get his knight in there he
didn't even need wasting no g5 resting
no time so Jeffrey said no I'm not
opening up the position now he's
probably planning okay if you played g5
I play each button right you play age
five I play g5 and I think we saw
basically exactly that the Queen got up
to a five Oh forcing the King up but
then we did we did see the move g5 by by
Geoffrey kind of a bold a bold move
there so that can be one idea you were
saying I guess Geoffrey tried to prevent
that with this Bishop c5 move of course
now you know it would be met with Bishop
d4 and ya know that Bishop c5 maybe if
Knight c5 would have seen King b1 by by
ruse Amba Bishop c5 Bishop d4 all of a
sudden it's gotta go the other way
absolutely gotta go the other way so he
did and although it looks like the Kings
kind of in the middle of the board again
we have to remember that the position is
so closed up here yeah and so the Kings
are not in Minas much danger as they
would be in another type of open
position right but yeah so in keeping
the position closed he did give up that
at five square right yes yes that was
the price I mean Jeffries gonna win that
pawn
I don't think Bruce Thames too concerned
about dropping the F pawn I mean this
Knight is actually really strong in any
type of end game hitting that pawn and
then you've got this guy ready to go but
the question is
rooo stems pieces i mean the end of the
day black sort of he seems to have done
well in the last couple news he won upon
the king when he ate is actually quite
fine these bishops are looking very very
powerful oops not from there very
powerful from a b7 and from c5 I'm a
little uncomfortable here if I'm roost
em yeah and again like the the problem
piece is always the rook on h8 but of
course in a closed structure like this
it seems like it's not gonna be as
important right you know writers you've
got time to try and extract that piece
yeah the other funny thing is I can
actually consider I think I can consider
castling right I haven't moved my yes so
now I could now if I want just sometimes
you forget forget the guy's been
choosing not to Castle not like he
couldn't but yes no I I think roost M is
going to play as we see him the rook f1
on the board I think ideally he would
maybe like his King sort of tucked away
over here if he could do that if you
move this Bishop I mean this night could
be hanging in a few lines like for
example if you Castle but otherwise I
think with a knight on c5 potentially
coming in we could see a lot of pressure
on this position roost n was actually
down ten minutes on the clock here and I
think the pressure in this position for
him might come from some sort of rook
takes d7 and then loosening up this ah
this broke on on f6 but I'm trying to
use the F file it's almost as though
White's running out of squares for his
pieces right yeah and so you might have
to you know I accept some trades some
Bishop f2 moves maybe just to get his
king where it needs to be in an maneuver
exactly yeah he might have to do this
the thing is the closer we get to an
endgame these dark square pawns I think
they're gonna favor black and the only
thing is that this knight on f5 might be
the savior for roost I'm hating this
pawn and that's just a constant
annoyance in any endgame so we're
talking about end games I don't even
think we're gonna make it one but with
10 extra minutes on the clock
I think Geoffrey is really going to
spend some times and look look to find
some accurate moves certainly to to make
things uncomfortable for roost em it's
funny blacks King was the one it used to
be in the middle of the board now
White's joined him and maybe his gang is
more exposed and I'm not sure feels like
that's something Geoffrey kind of
specializes in
at the critical moment really you know
taking a minute and finding the you know
the key the key moved to really put a
opponent under some pressure right it
does look like we have another result I
think Benjamin Bach Bach drew a re-tuck
re ontari okay it's the big news I guess
is you know it looks like var might have
actually slipped up in in his game here
and let's jump back to those of these
games are in extreme time pressure chasm
jenoff down to a minute a Kobe and made
his last move with four seconds and this
I mean this is the game to to look at
here right yeah is it rook d8 maybe
trade and King takes d8 it looks like
e6000 it's er Tinley does I mean really
eight was was one of those moves and
maybe you play quickly but again if I
take there's not a nice way to take that
back because of all the pins so work d8
actually you have to play King takes d8
not sure if Rey is thinking about a
different move like maybe check first
maybe he's thinking about throwing this
in and right I'm rook d6 idea cuz this
is that very nasty looks very nasty this
is definitely a consideration let's
remember 98 it's not possible because
Queen takes c8 in this position I'm
actually not sure what to do here this
looks just looks crushing I think Laura
no this looks crushing after check I
might have to go somewhere else yeah I
might have to go somewhere this is just
a no so it's got to be King c7 here I
guess but even even that surely there's
there's some way to yeah well I take
advantage of that this looks like a
great move rook d6 looks like a great
move Queen e6 it's at the very least a
decent movie right of course I'm taking
that bond but it feels to me like Ray
sees you smells blood here
rook d1 looks like the big consideration
Queen takes c6 great move so that
there's almost maybe maybe you know
allowing black to escape a little bit
with something like Queen to d7 and then
trying to run somewhere with the key
with the King right also should just
should just be winning as well
yeah I think he's got a few ways to
approach the position because maybe it's
a tough decision sometimes you get that
choice where everything's you feel like
it's winning but which one is more
winning or which one do you prefer it's
very hard to pass up at least for me you
know when you see like okay I know for a
fact I can take this e6 pawn yeah you
know Rick do you one looks better but I
just have to you know triple check
quadruple check make sure I'm not just
growing away this free chance exactly
you don't want to miss a free win a
queen takes c6 Queen d7 I mean there's
also the like hey let me just like grab
all your pawns
right and this can work very well too so
rook t1 looks like looks like a very
good move though based on my
calculations seems to have been played
on the board as well okay so he went
rook d-1 VAR very quickly played king c7
yeah these King moves are not options
rook d6 is game over or Queen takes c6
depending where you go but King there
and now rook d6 94 and Queen e6 all come
to mind here trying to decide which one
is the best let's say if 94 threatening
to play Queen takes c6 check let's say
Queen b6 by black and we have a choice
here but I feel like once that King gets
to once that King gets down to b8 I
don't necessarily have a follow up maybe
Roman g6 first puts more pressure and
then try to bring the knight in yeah
still Queen b6 here maybe and then right
somehow just king b7 trying to unpin
everything right so now now everybody's
pinned yeah it's like nobody can move
I'm inclined to play just a waiting move
here cuz basically black is is stuck
like rook takes c6 or something it feels
like I can almost keep waiting it's
their queen takes d4 though then Queen
d4 is just just good here is there some
I guess there's there's not I was
thinking of rookie 7 but I think King b6
is just fine for black right okay I
thought everything was pinned but
everything wasn't no yeah so my knight
is actually hanging so I can't do that
one Knight takes D 6 or
six looks like a good move here as well
you really feel like you're spoiled for
for a move oh yeah I mean there's always
the simple option of bailing out and
taking on a six and then of course you
know blacks made a lot of weaknesses on
the kingside so probably this one - this
one that's a real pin okay that's an
actual one and then I am threatening to
sort of pick up all these pawns in the
position so yeah I don't think Raya is
really the type to to have problems in
in these not conversions that are
technical but they're almost just
tactical conversions at this point yeah
just you know finding the right series
of moves to really keep your opponent
pinned down mm-hmm keep them from
escaping right let's see what else is
going on do you want to check out a live
a group look in the B group yeah it
looks like a Stein Grimson has actually
made quite a bit of progress in this
game against a Christian yeah we can we
can check in with this one I think that
gorilla is like absolutely lost but I
haven't haven't seen exactly but again
he's trying to make it come back from
two central pawns and in the position
and this is not how your your grünfeld
position is supposed to go of course not
I guess that's an exchange sacrifice it
is it is no he's he's in a really weird
position here Knight h6 and he's hanging
on by like the weirdest threat but it
does look like at the end of the day
because he because he's up the exchange
that he's always willing to sacrifice it
back right yeah something like sixty six
seems to be a day for weird
configurations of pieces that all kind
of hold each other together just
brightly I think that he's just played
the bishop takes f8 rook takes FA and
I'm not sure as he played Knight takes
h7 on the board there it looks like he
did yeah I think that's a white knight
on h7 so he's saying like I'm gonna play
Knight h7 Knight f6 and push all these
pawns like I've got five connected pawns
here that's certainly I think that might
just be his game plan what white seems
to be better here but again Carrillo
seems to be the most
every player in the event so far very
tough to pin that guy down bad MMA
training once that f7 pawn drops it
seems as though you know there's nothing
stopping White's Center puns so feels to
me like you know blacks pieces are
really gonna be tied down to that square
specifically something like 95 here for
example and then yep
95 has just been played by white move 31
these players at three minutes apiece
but it looks like Stein Grimson is is in
control still despite the material I
think that was rather more like an
intentional side right
yeah and Carillo seems to be still
playing from the back foot but nine more
moves of time pressure to go we'll see
if he can that's here in his position
around and have some good fortune mm-hmm
it looks like birch bullets is
equalizing and his game against Mistah
we've got a bishop end game here so
which what was his choice
this was our important game to watch in
the B group and in this position okay he
went for them of a three and basically
just went for the the full two bishop
type of endgame position ha and he
wanted to simplify with the move g4 oh
yeah I guess that move makes quite a bit
of sense yeah and then I I guess this is
winning the pawn back but you're
accepting maybe a slight weakness with
the pawn on f5 yeah they're gonna be
double pawns and black sort of has this
idea to to go take it I wonder if he's
he's doing that he he plays King there
and I think it's because white was
actually just gonna walk all the way
into b6 if you put that King over there
and maybe even being up a pond you might
risk losing maybe there's also f4 for
white if you if I play King f6 you mean
yeah king of six maybe f4 I guess do a
g4 I think I'll play I mean if I'm if
I'm trying to show anything here I got a
playwright for and I'll still try to
take this and I've got the outside pawn
now it's a little dangerous but yeah I'm
not so happy with my move out for now
that the opponent
running originally I thought I could
just play King f2 and King g3 you are in
time to take my pawn on f5 right so yeah
if I'm if I'm playing white here I like
the fact that this guy's actually
holding off the Jeep on for the moment
and I think this is our current position
here black I mean if he ever goes and
sort of grabs this pawn the White King
invades over here right and you get the
feeling that you're gonna be able to let
me explain the move
I think Bishop e2 King e6 on the board
and we'll probably see something like
this yeah simply doesn't look like
enough for black right you know the
bishop can always sacrifice for the last
pawn if need be and let's see here it's
probably probably going to play this
yeah I guess I just saved the bishop
somehow maybe Bishop g4 try to keep
entertaining a little locked out maybe
came here and he's trying to say that
you can't take the pawn because of being
a or maybe Bishop c8 is possible he's
making Danger Danger there yeah I mean I
guess are we just gonna get some
position where and just in time maybe
two Queen for both sides and I think
everybody just gets the Queen safely
here and everybody everybody walks away
with the Queen right so that's a long
variation but it almost looks like a
variation that both of these guys have
to at least consider very very carefully
course so yeah I would say this one
looks very draw right yeah I don't think
anybody's gonna gonna win the son game
and if anybody does of course it's not
gonna be first bullet since that's right
Alexander Mista so that's right why
shouldn't she feeling pretty happy about
him and actually looks like we've got a
result var has resigned his game against
Trey Robson Wow so did not manage
signing the score sheet there and a way
to escape ya know that this rook d6 move
followed by Knight d4 it was just too
many pins it was sort of what we were
looking at he didn't even bother playing
the move Queen there because I think if
I just take here and you're just
permanently
there's nothing to do about that no way
to even move the pieces so yeah in this
position you're also threatening those
ideas like sometimes you have like rook
takes c6 and 98 sometimes 95 is a killer
move Plus let's not forget I can just
keep taking pawns so he plays a 95
blenders - Queen d5 and I guess is there
a I mean a cert reason uh d7 just 95
right I would just makes you alive yeah
the knight is hanging as well as the
fork and so there's no way to defend
both yep that's nasty and that's a win
for Ray Robson and Varco bian goes down
here the French has been really put out
there I mean for better for worse for
our sticks to his guns and yeah he beat
Eve on chicken in the French this
tournaments yeah absolutely that was you
know quite a nice game from him if I
remember correctly but so yeah do you
want to take another look at that
Geoffrey Jean game it seems like from
the YouTube chat I'm hearing something
well this is the last matchup this is
the last matchup ongoing in e8 group
right and it's pretty key for the
tournament standings overall as chasm
jennife can try to play spoiler here
right way down in the table but he's
sitting in a position where Jeffrey's
getting lower and lower on time and
Kasim Jenna of seems to have improved
his position yeah white a lot since the
last time he looks very confusing for me
cuz you know I might have forgotten the
castle Inglis legal but I would assume
Geoffrey remembers and it seems like a
much more natural way to develop his
pieces and get his King to safety then
this weird King walked to d8 in Ch it's
funny because it looks like he cast with
Queen but if we remember here this rook
is actually from here and this rope came
all the way from from a weighted sum so
some weird stuff but what did chasm
general do that I that I like I like
this move Bishop c4 Bishop d5 and he's
trying to get rid of these lights for
bishops that was something way early on
in the game I mentioned he wants to do
and I mean he hasn't forgotten that he
he's got his King on e2 but he remembers
the principles they're trade those
LightSquared bishop s-- get access to
those squares and this
Knight is gonna be like an absolute hero
later on in any position this is gonna
be a real thorn in Jeffrey's side takes
and we just shift the pieces to the C
file where blacks King is now so I think
Jeffrey is actually feeling feeling the
pressure here I think you just made a
move as well King to be eight and now
it's on Rue Stan yeah
maybe King F three looks reasonable to
my eyes I I don't see why this this King
is on b8 I would rather still have it on
on g8 and take three less moves too you
know right because you have so many
things to get out of the way of from d8
you have to get out of the way the D
file yeah or you have to get out of the
C file here you have to get out of the
bishop and even there the split Bishop
e5 so there's there's no safe space over
there I don't know why why the Jeffry
chose this this decision but if he makes
it to a7 the promise maybe maybe that's
the safest square but B I think that I
think that this is very very tense
position as we see a trade of bishops on
b5 and that was Bishop takes pawn takes
mhm
and Bruce them to move the reason I like
Bruce times position is that I don't I
don't feel like I have to play it
tactically anymore
right I feel like even trading the
Queen's I'm happy because this guy is
such a monster yeah I mean you are you
hear the the classic saying you know a
good night on a good outpost is worth
the rook and sometimes that you know
manifests literally you know the knight
is pinning down black's rook on ideas
yeah it really has no options to go
anywhere until this note is dealt with
yeah rook d1 has been played and I'm
starting to really like Bruce times
position despite the time he's only two
moves away from time control and he's
gonna get that extra time and I think
it's just so comfortable you sit there
with your King on f3 King when he to
even you can reroute this bishop and
there's just so many dark square targets
for for White's pieces to to attack with
that Knight and Bishop there I think
that roost M is actually turning the
tables and what a spoiler that would be
that would give Lily a nation ik clear
lead in the a group so we'll have to
stay tuned and see what happens there
but this is the last remaining game in
the a group currently ongoing
and just two more moves to play until
the time control for them looks like
they've got they're pretty low on time
but it should be enough right it should
be enough it's not so hard to find moves
to play for white here and then black
does have five minutes remaining so
that's right there's a game that we
haven't taken a look at I think that's
Sergey Arenberg in the B group against
Nicolas Teodoro
now I see that white has just made the
40th move that was the move Bishop d8
and so black will follow suit and get
that 30 extra minutes but Arenberg was
actually really low on time in this game
started off as a Berlin I think it was
right around this point that black
actually had like a 1 hour time
advantage Wow so he he was clearly in
some sort of theory of some sort of prep
he knew what he was doing but that being
said ehrenburg's position looks quite
reasonable I mean he's got everything
locked up and there's just sort of an
extra pawn sitting there on c7 Black has
the two bishops but that guy on c6 it's
not doing very well there if it can
reroute to f5 and maybe get to see two
that starts to look really scary for
white but on its own White has sort of
the perfect structure to restrict that
bishop this is actually the only player
in the tournament that I have some
experience with I've actually played a
Nicolas in a rated game before and I did
manage to lose that one but something
that stuck in my mind was you know he
played his prep very quickly he played
the opening very quickly and then it's
seemingly you know the first move out he
really got got into a tank so uh right
it seems like you know he really uses
that time once he gets out of prep just
you know be certain of his plan for the
game and how he wants to continue yeah I
guess you may as well if you're as well
prepared as some of these guys in the a
and B groups here I mean you don't want
to waste time in the open because I see
the middle games that these guys are
getting and some of the end games I mean
we've seen so many examples in both
groups in this spring Classic so far
where if they just had more time in the
end game we wouldn't be blundering as
we've seen some some incredible
evaluation swings that really are are
caused by time pressure yeah so what did
end up happening
so I mean we've got this classic to to
Bishop position but Nicholas I think was
was really feeling the pressure from
whites night because the way that these
pawns were arranged once a night arrives
on d5 I mean if you play c6 then you've
had this bond hanging and if you don't
then this long-distance Bishop from h2
makes it really hard to stop so he
actually was forced to exchange music
forced to exchange those those pieces
off and that's not something you
generally want to do and yet I guess
this looks like a you know an exchange
of puns black is probably happy with
right right giving up c7 and b6 but you
know taking b3 getting as your ex active
yep and I think this was the last move
of the game rook c2 d2 was the move by
theodoro and white still has to be
careful here I mean there's ideas like
Bishop f4 and getting mated for white so
this is not just a walk in the park here
for either player despite wiping up a
pawn on the Kings side that King is
really locked away and it can be in some
serious trouble
certainly some danger here I guess rook
takes f6 with Czech would actually be a
losing move because of something like
King g7 we do see here on the camera it
looks like Christian has resigned his
game so he did not manage to a comeback
despite having you know that that extra
exchange it looks like the pawns were
probably too much the final position is
a little bit remarkable as well as white
actually has five connected pass pawns
wow that's a lot okay dealing with five
connected bonds I mean there's not a not
a piece on on the chessboard
I think everyone gorilla especially
included would prefer to be down a rope
than five connected passed pawns but
just just going back a little bit the
reason this was just such a easy
conversion despite the quote-unquote
material that that it looks like gorilla
has here for the for the piece it's just
that these pawns get going so fast d5 d6
f4 I mean this is just beautiful nothing
to do
do and that f7 fun does fall and that
was kind of the last you know the last
offender preventing these these pawns
from rolling through yeah so this is
Kirill is tough tough outing he had a
tough game yesterday which miraculously
held to a draw but now he sort of put a
damper on experience did Stein Grimson
who wins here late in the tournament I
don't think he's been having a great
event either so no but it's nice to see
him walking away with a with a point
right you can finish strong still the
other game that's sort of developing in
the the B group is the one with Kai
Donovan Sorokin which we checked earlier
now this game was the one I think we
were expecting maybe a one pawn
advantage for white after some
complications he did actually go for
this 92 move that you had mentioned a
long time ago when we were on this game
right and it sort of seemed like one of
those bailout options you just have to
get rid of that night on C right
absolutely
but then yeah so white does just capture
and now he worked d1 and we're up to
pawns here with wipe and this guy looks
like it's it's going to be going to be
captured or if we could that would be
the one that grabbed some Knight d4 I
guess and then maybe there's tactics if
you play Bishop takes d7 I have Bishop
takes c6 right that's looking good
probably why as we're following the game
94 he felt the yet to play Knight tasty
for writes I'm not falling for any
tricks and saying look I'm going to take
that pawn on g7 next but I think this is
just a big advantage for white here the
strong thinking potential for a passed
pawn here as well and just basically no
weaknesses for white at all nothing
nothing for black to do really but try
and hold yeah so he's gonna get these
funds going he's got a super strong
passed pawn on c6 defended by the bishop
black took the the time after Queen
takes c6 to play rook e1 check the idea
being to grab that Queen on d6 so King
h2 more or less forced and we did see
him play the move Queen takes d6 rook
takes d6 and in this position he's
having
but if they think but that is we're well
past move 40 here so these guys have
their 30 extra minutes and well I don't
see white just completely winning on the
spot and me black is gonna put that rook
on c1 and always be difficult to advance
yeah
it's tough to tell if this is enough to
win right maybe it relies on white doing
something with the a pawn maybe trying
to take advantage of that that a5 fun
being a little bit sidelined while black
is trying to prevent the pawn for
pushing further can you see any any
winning ideas well if I could sort of
trade this pawn for this pawn that might
be reasonable because it's really nice
to control the queening square from a
position that also defends my my king
but right it's really hard to imagine
that the move rookie two doesn't get
played because that Forks two pawns and
I have the idea to play rook to c2 next
and get behind that C pawn so actually
rookie two is on the board and that just
looks very logical trying to sell one of
these yeah rookie - if c7 then is Rick
c2 being played right away well do we
have to play it I mean it seems just
incredibly greedy not to play it yeah
but then I was thinking maybe bishop c64
for white kept two pieces on the board
and also you know threatens maybe
eventually something like g4 and playing
Rick d8 just getting that rook in front
of the pawn well let's play this then
let's play let's play the greedy move
okay uh rook takes so let's say mmm it's
actually tough here I guess what if
chief g4 is there Bishop a4 yes
I want to say I want to say yes cuz I'm
gonna take and give you this check and
grab your queen there alright well I
don't know maybe it's maybe stuff that
maybe the c7 move isn't available to
play and we actually have the winner of
the game against VAR waiting to come in
here ray Robson is going to come in
he hasn't joined us in the studio yet so
that's going to be interesting to see so
on if you want to you know analyze a
little bit more of this game or take
another look at Ray's game let's get him
in the studio absolutely
I'll be nice to be joined by Grandmaster
Ray Robson after what looked like a very
exciting game against vara Cobian so we
have this game here between kay Donovan
Sorokin still going in the in the B
group we also had Ehrenberg and Theodora
in a rather interesting position as well
as the the game between bars poets and
Alexander Mistah that I bring up on the
screen right now bars poets here both of
these guys by the way hit time control
but it seems to me like there shouldn't
be anything anything between them if
white plays like King a5 for example I'm
trying to see what black intends to do
here but I imagine that these guys are
going to be potentially shuffling pieces
and just just looking to to draw this
one I don't see a way to make progress
here for for either side really black
might consider stuff like this but you
can never do that while I mean the
bishop is still here so I think this one
is probably probably headed towards say
a draw jumping back to the game in the a
group which is still going the only ones
still going things have gotten pretty
crazy in this one is they've actually
players have actually hit time control
and custom jonov is already six minutes
into those extra thirty as this position
has gotten pretty complicated here early
on it looked like maybe Geoffrey was was
favorite but Kasim jennife seemed to be
taking over in the in the last couple of
moves but in the meantime we're gonna be
joined by Grandmaster Ray Robson in the
studio haven't joined us so far so it's
really nice to have you here
Thanks yeah nice to be here we just
looked at the game that you played
against var and love it honestly if you
could take us through some of the
highlights of the game and where you
think things got interesting because we
saw that pong Sakura Lee and then things
look really interesting
yeah point on well I think it was
already interesting right at the
beginning where you said it with the
pawn sacrifice all right we have art
played the French as he usually does and
he's already played this line like a few
times it's too early it's like the third
time or getting this tournament so
obviously he has some experience here
and I think he'd done pretty well he
hadn't lost any of his games he might
have even think he beat one yeah them so
yeah he sees he sticks to his guns yeah
so he plays a 692 and here he played
Queen b6 which he hadn't played before I
think he played Brady five before yeah
or Bishop e7 mm-hmm so Queen b6 is
probably the most critical move and here
Y has two ways to protect the pawn
either with the queen queen c1 or which
i think is the main move or what could
be one yeah so I played work b1 yeah and
now probably the most critical way black
good place to buy f6 challenging the
center and then c3 and now he could
either take on d4 just played Bishop e7
Castle quickly and keeps pressure on
white center right but so what he did is
also probably completely playable Queen
a5 check so now Bishop d2 and he doesn't
really want to take the a to pawn I
can't trap him immediately but his queen
is not gonna get out right itself so he
just goes back and the idea is that he's
misplaced my bishop so it's kind of like
I played I played rook b1 and my red
ship from e3 back to d2 and his move us
Queen d8 to c7 exactly so it's kind of
who who came out on top here I think I
mean the rook come b1 isn't worse but
the bishop is around the other hand
Queen c7 isn't you know why he would
normally want to play so um so here's c3
is protecting the center yeah I've
and yeah now f5 yeah and I knew of this
idea but I thought it's just unclear I
thought white has enough compensation
but I hadn't looked at anything deeply
right I think we were wondering whether
this was sort of something you you had a
real idea about or is this was sort of
instincts and I just thought it would be
an interesting ya position wrong there
yeah and he also he knew this he said
there was a game I think was sure of
which he said black one so okay yeah he
takes Knight f4 so my knight gets this
nice outpost on f4 mmm-hmm attacking d5
he's forced to play Knight b6 and I get
to develop my pieces really quickly this
seemed pretty this is how I would expect
black to play just sort of try to plug
in a position you hang on to that pond
he wants to put something on e6 ideally
he might even want to put his knight
98-96 but he might have to watch out for
well in the game if he'd done that I
might have had a 485 ideas right um so
he most likely he'll put his bishop on
e6 but if he does it now let's say right
now I might yeah I might have something
like g4 right and if he takes then 96
and 95 and his structure is kind of
collapsing so he that's the one thing he
needs to watch out for when he puts his
bishop on e6 right make sure he's got
that move covered so say you played c4
which I don't think it's bad but just
thank you I think you could have just
played Bishop e7 I don't think I'm gonna
take yeah I was wondering whether he
played c4 because he thought that you
might take and open up the position and
it wasn't clear whether his King had a
safe place to go so yeah I think he also
likes these structures with like the
closed structures close finish I
remember a long time ago I had training
with him I think in like 2009 and he
showed me some games where he was black
in like the advanced French where he
played with c4 okay
yeah and he just outplayed his opponent
so I think he he likes to have your
you're going back to the 2009 stories
and you're you're using it against them
right okay but yeah that using the
tendencies but yeah c4 was played I mean
like you said it's not a bad move but it
does sort of make your your
a little easier it sort of clarifies the
structure Bishop C to Bishop e7 is
logical here yeah I was debating whether
to play B three or a four the idea of a
four is like if a for Bishop e6 I was
wondering like maybe I play rook a1 and
try to make him decide what to do is
over there because I want him to Castle
kingside
I don't think he wants to Castle King
said if he doesn't I have a clear target
and I can start that because the
structure is so closed if his King just
stays in the center it's really hard for
me to do anything so right that's kind
of the issue I think I think b3 was
obviously logical whether an after
Bishop e6 for this to like really be
working for me I'd have to be able to
play g4 right which I still don't think
he should take but after g4 because if
he takes on g4 I play 96 f e6 95 and if
Bishop g5 Bishop takes g5 and you can't
Castle queenside which is or good yeah
yeah or King Simon I'm taking g4 and
you're gonna rock f6 so yeah problem was
after g4 I thought he'll just play Queen
d7 and if I ever take on e6 he's always
taking back with the F pawn solid and
now if I'm taking an f5 he can take back
with a piece with the first with the
bishop and then if I take take the game
with the Queen I can take on c4 here
then I thought maybe just D takes c4 and
unless I can play d5 quickly yes just
not working for me yeah it has to be
concrete so I couldn't really make
anything concrete work so I just
continued slowly with Queen e1 I don't I
want to put my queen and g3 probably but
after that I didn't really have a clear
plan but right it's not clear what he's
gonna do either because his King doesn't
have yeah he doesn't want to go clear he
said obviously but Queen side then at
some point I'll play a four and open up
the Queen side yeah so that's kind of
what happened we kind of both just made
slightly useful yeah it seemed like
everyone was sort of improving their
position more or less h4 four hours
yeah I want to play maybe h5 or just 95
and also just preventing him from thank
Jesus what a 5 was surprising to me
I wasn't expecting him to try to open up
the queenside because yeah this is a
pretty inspired plan here yeah I don't
know I thought maybe he'd just play
something like age six or even if he
just waited because now it's clear he
wants to play b4 mm-hmm
but now especially after he also played
rook c8 his king is clearly stuck to the
center and so if we open up the Queen
side I think that's in my favor in
general
mm-hm and once the Queen side is open
I'm gonna be able to penetrate they're
forcing his King to the Kings side which
is what I want so I was actually happy
that he went for this rice plan so yeah
I just rerouted my Bishop to e2 on c2 is
also there's some discovered attacks
once the C file open with his rope can
raise a ship so I just put it on e - and
now yeah h6 is kind of funny such a
tense position just HSHS h6 but he now
he has g5 ideas at some moment
potentially he's trying to expand
everywhere on the board it seems like
yeah and here here was like a critical
decision I had to choose between either
playing rook e1 like I did which is
preparing to take on c4 and try to open
up with d5 or I could have taken on c4
immediately those ran into your options
I thought so maybe be c4 immediately was
better and ideas is let's say D takes c4
the Newark d1 and you can never really
put his knight on d5 which she's loved
too because I take e 6 and then C force
C four pawns hanging right yeah and and
a lot of lines I'll even sacrifice with
that's a d5 next move Knight takes d5
then I take the same thing 96 and Bishop
c4 and I've opened up the position a lot
yeah after he takes c4 he could also
play Knight c4 right here yeah
Bishop takes c4 d takes c4 rook f d1 and
let's say Bishop d5 I was thinking about
a 6 so now if Bishop e6 I think I have d
555 Bishop e3
yes it's off to East six he can take
with the pawn still Queen takes g6 King
d8 and you might think his cannon d8 is
really weak but and a lot of these lines
his King and his center is really hard
to get it and right somehow once he gets
to e6 f5 structure it's hard to break
through so yeah I thought I have maybe
Nighy 5 here try to open the D fall at
least Knight takes e5 d takes e5 and
yeah I just wasn't sure if this was good
or not he goes just like King c-17 just
try to like I almost I don't know
establish some sort of blockade yeah
maybe I can just take before because my
knight on that 4 is good at protecting
g2 but I wasn't sure
right yeah so rook FD 1 is definitely
less Camillo because if B takes e4
doesn't work it could just be bad for me
mm-hmm rook FD 1 now I'm trying to take
c4 and and do okay if he's taking on c3
I'm at least fine so he took him played
Bishop before which is interesting I
didn't think he would work but um maybe
it is actually so he's clearing the e7
square for his knight which will be a
really good protector of both g6 and
especially d5 once I take on c4 yeah so
if I play something slow like just rooks
BC 1 he'll probably play 97 and I
thought everything is protected now if
you ever take yeah we've got it covered
and I didn't think that was working for
me so the other way was Bishop before
which I had calculated and I thought was
actually and did you think that this
would actually got kind of forcing at
least the sequence yeah he went for
right mm-hmm
take take d5 yeah this if I take on e6
instead of playing d5 then again the
point is if Queen e6 I have the same
idea of d5 and Bishop c4 right this
homme but I thought he'll take back with
the pawn again getting the same
structure Queen g6 just Queen f7 a queen
oh seven notes and yeah his Knights
protect those two pawns yes and yeah
everything is protected and I have no
breakthroughs and now his pawn on c4 is
quite strong it's gonna get to c3 I'll
be very annoying so I felt like I had to
play d5 and go for this mm-hmm yeah it's
saying it's one of those moves you just
almost play with that you just need to
play it and initially I thought this was
good for me I thought I would at least
have a
compensation but then once we got closer
I realized that at the end of this
forced line after queen a7 check making
make sense getting out the pin was check
yeah take stakes so initially I thought
you'd have to take on c4 right and then
Queen takes c4 probably castles and then
I play something like Queen back to f4
and maybe King g7 and I have an
initiative I'm down upon but I have
ideas like h5 or 56 he's sick so and he
had very little time so did you think
that maybe something like this might be
better than then the game because the
game is also quite a loose position and
maybe tough to play and in time pressure
as well during the game I I was happy
with this position for white I don't
know what it is objectively maybe he can
just take a too quickly if I try to 56
and just push his pawn I don't know
knows but I had missed g5 at first by
this time I'd already expect it is well
yeah I completely missed g5 which isn't
great yeah yeah I can't because of the
discovered check and I'm almost just
losing a piece I have to play Queen c1
it's unfortunate that this line wasn't
just losing and now if he moves his
Knight - in my bishop I have at least
have a check so I'm at least not losing
the bishop which is important yeah so
after the game he thought that 97 was
just winning for him but he missed I
have robotics before so I hear you yeah
he thought this was winning but I think
oh I don't think I'm losing I don't know
if I'm better or not here
I actually thought a knight a 5 maybe
was interesting and then Bishop b5
checking go even kini 7 is interesting
because if he can exchange Queens he'd
rather have this king up there so let's
say Queen d2 Queen c5 and he's just
trying to get his room to d8 and get
exchange Queen so uh yeah I wasn't sure
about this I thought maybe he's fine
here I can play Queen d6 check but I
wasn't sure about the endgame YUM you're
looking for more than yeah I was hoping
for more like yeah his King was in the
center he didn't have any time at all so
but instead of king e7 was probably a
blunder but castles was another option
but then it looked like I could play H
takes g5 and the point is if he plays
and ie7 let's say
pinning my bishop I just take on h6 rook
takes c4 Queen g5 check knight c6 and
now Queen f6 and it's actually kind of
sad for black that isn't I had to go to
g6 because he blocks Ritchie 4 which
would protect yourself right yeah and so
now I'm just made her gauge floor is
covered as well also but apparently
someone told me that the engine says
castles is better for black because
after castles H takes g5 there's Knight
a5 g takes h6 and now Queen e7 so he
kept the e7 score open for his queen and
he guards everything now if Queen f4
yeah does have this rope c4 and then
real quick g4 idea blocking everything
right so yeah this one concrete line
would have worked for him okay but he
was also in a position where it's very
tough to find these types of lines with
with the time situation
he played King g7 which I'm sure is a
big mistake
you know after it takes takes and when
he first played it I didn't see anything
clear but then I saw Queen c4 is very
strong I want to play rook d6 and Queen
c4 but if I had gone room d6 immediately
he'd have Knight takes e5 yes yeah so
Queen c4 is the same idea I've
unfortunate that rook t8 is actually
like he has to take with his king yeah
his Knight has always pinned all right
and if he takes on e5 with the knight
now I can take on before check and then
his knight on e5 ok yeah so I thought
his only chance was after Queen c4
I thought his only chance was my a5
Queen takes b4 check Queen c5 probably
because his Knight at least controls b7
and if I play something like green a4
maybe rook HTA's rip da like rook takes
d8 rook d8
rook could be 5 Queen c1 king h2 and
maybe it's still just winning I didn't
know I didn't have time to calculate
sure it was winning or not yeah but
otherwise rook could d6 was just coming
at his position was crumbling so he
played rotate to stop that but yeah he
had no good way to recapture
yeah this is unfortunate I think here
you were just putting the finishing
touches kind of on the calculations here
yeah I was just trying to decide I was
just trying to find a forced way yeah
you have a lot of good options I think
what I did was good
Kimsey 75067 looked forced 94 and here
if Knight takes d4 then rook d7 check
King b8 I could take a b4 check and his
queen is always hanging yeah so I
thought Queen b6 was force and then I
was just gonna take on e6 with the night
and yeah he's just tied down almost
every but I could have done the same
thing with his King mb8 but I didn't
because here if Queen f2 this position
and the other line if I ever take on c6
he can take back and he'll have
perpetual with Queen h4 chuckle anyone
check but here if I take c6 rook c6 I
have 98 check and I take on c6 with the
night you know where he goes it's a
check and my queen protects h4 so I
think it's just winning yep so I didn't
said he played Queen a4 she made it a
little bit easier I see six now my rook
also controls d1 just in case just no
checks and his Queen and King are on
unfortunately right yeah yeah so then at
this point this is just between d5 and
something will fall just take the knight
yeah yeah yeah so yeah actually the the
end of that game it probably came down
maybe to castle or a king e7 like looked
really complicated but maybe he was even
in with the show at the end but probably
just because of the time pressure that
he couldn't calculate all that right
yeah yeah well late in the tournament
it's nice to score a a win obviously
there's one more round tomorrow so be
looking to see where you finish in the
standings but hopefully we get to hear
from you again I mean another good
result and congrats on the victory today
thanks yeah and I don't know what's
happening in Jeffrey's game but I guess
I have a chance to be tied for the lead
again if he doesn't yet knowing in Jeff
Rees game I think this is the current
position right now Jeffrey's position
looked looked a little suspicious
earlier Queen takes c6 was the last move
here so okay
there's temporary okay so he's gonna
take the Queen at some point and he'll
take the night and look for some checks
there we've seen some crazy games drawn
by perpetual checks yeah and I'm
actually playing Jeffrey the last game
tomorrow well there you go that that
sets the stage beautifully for the the
final round well good luck in that game
and thanks a lot for your comments and
joining us in the studio thank you
that's Grandmaster Ray Robson after his
win against version of Cobian here in
the a group we're in round 8 and this is
the final game ongoing right now roost
I'm Kasim Shanna of against Geoffrey
Zhang this one is really important for
the tournament standings as Geoffrey was
currently I mean he was on top of the of
the tournament table before the round
and Illya nish Nick is actually poised
along with Ray Robson to take over that
lead if roost I'm Kasim jonov can play
spoiler here which is looks like what
he's sort of set out to do he's way down
on time but this position looks like
maybe the most Geoffrey can hope for is
a perpetual it's kind of hard to say
Queen g2 has just been played yeah I'm
inclined to agree I'm back in the chair
again a super interesting interview from
Ray there that was quite the game you
played with fire but yeah worth more to
it than met Thea absolutely at least
that met my eye all right so yeah like
you said it looks like you know why it's
going to be material up if black simply
takes on e6 so black is searching for a
perpetual doesn't look like he's gonna
find one I guess is the question here
yeah I think in the in the B group Mista
and Barcia pullets did draw so it's
actually by ginchy who's really sort of
cementing himself at the top of the
leaderboard absolutely in that one
Sorokin and Qaeda and I'm still battling
out along with with Arenberg and
Theodora but I think it's this Geoffrey
Jean game which is the most the most
interesting at the moment as I mean you
got a queen hanging on e6 and I mean
he's played Queen g2 but I don't believe
in the perpetual I'm sort of curious
what
whether he can run his King away and
whether he loses material in order to
keep playing the game
right there might also be some strange
fork going on right I had a lot of
weirdly place pieces it's it's more than
I'm able to ever calculate but something
like this he wants to take here and
right you know if Queen here we can
always sort of defend things Queen g3
also not an exact fork because king c2
so it does look like like Kasim Jana
should be the one who's pushing here in
the same game he has played the Move
King d3 so Jeffries probably gonna try
to maximize that time advantage here
absolutely he says he's got to if he
wants any chance yeah I mean he also has
to make use of it here right to really
find out what's the best way to continue
or is the only move F takes c6 here
actually mm-hmm yeah he has a few checks
he can throw in first Queen f3 Queen III
though and wait a minute you know I'm
not getting that Queen after a halt so
yeah yeah you uh you get the rope on d1
but the Queen I guess is the more
valuable I may be a little yeah and we
do see f take c6 Knight takes d six on
the board and Kasim jonov here is going
to look to see if you can find some
coordination I think as soon as you you
sort of coordinate those pieces around
and maybe connect the rooks or or
somehow get the knight back into the
action then you're you're doing fine but
this rook on a3 is actually really
awkward at the moment and something like
Queen d5 king c2 maybe even like Queen
c5
it's the Brooke I'm wondering if there
are any any type of tricky checks where
somehow I've got like three weirdly
placed pieces I can't defend them all
right yeah
so with that game in minds you know I
guess it's time to you know take a look
at you know our standings after round
eight and our pairings for the next
round see what's gonna be going on so
yeah with that draw Illya pushes his
score up to five and Ray taking that
full point off of our Kobe and now joins
him in the leading role this Geoffrey
Jean game looks like it's totally up in
the air it could be a draw could be a
win could be a loss all depending on you
know the
these next few moves here you know that
game is totally up in the air and it
actually means quite a lot for the
standings because we could have a
three-way tie at the top absolutely as
you just heard from Grandmaster Ray
Robson when he was in the studio he's
playing Geoffrey tomorrow in the final
round so that could be a battle between
two guys with five points right on top
of the table certainly a game to see
just trailing them as our entire at four
and a half points after today so with a
win tomorrow he might also find himself
you know in a playoff for the for the
win exactly yeah no I think anyone there
in the four and a half five group is
poised to potentially share first place
and tournament it don't forget we do
have those tie breaks those playoffs
absolutely if necessary and then of
course you know trailing them no blood
was shed today besides that the Ray
Robson game so far and you know the rest
of the field managed to draw right and
then let's check out the B group here
see how they're doing after round eight
so of course you know by should she that
we've been talking about all tournament
still in the lead by a full point with
six so all he needs tomorrow would be a
draw to secure the win that's right
Varsha bullets is the nearest trailer at
five points with a draw today and yeah
well I think that Lexi Sorokin I think
by looking at the tournament that he's
in in the average rating I would say but
plus one is required for for his norm so
he probably needs to hold this game and
and let's say tomorrow score score
another draw absolutely so he probably
needs around five points I would say in
this field don't forget he was the
lowest rated coming into this field he
was the bottom seed right and it kind of
depends whether he can hold this game
today and how his game goes tomorrow but
he has got a few things on its mind he's
got that norm to also try to secure all
right yeah and then uh of course
Nicholas Theodore the other player
looking for Knorr in this event sadly
not going to get them it seems with only
three out of you know the the seven
games and yes
no I it would be obviously he'd need to
win his next two games and I don't even
that how that would look absolutely well
we have a lot of exciting broadcasts
coming up actually not only this
tournament but in a couple weeks there
will have the US Championships and the
US women's championships actually going
on right here at the st. Louis chess
club so we'll see a lot of these
familiar faces back we'll see var here
we'll see Jeffrey here we'll see ray
here who's just in the studio yep and
yeah that'll be a tournament to watch
for sure that's always a really exciting
tournament and obviously pretty much all
those guys are gray and in Jeffrey in
great form in this tournament so be
exciting to see how they do in the US
Championship and so tomorrow is going to
be our final rounds and if necessary we
will also be having the playoffs
tomorrow all right if that's accurate so
we're actually gonna be starting early
in case of those playoffs so it'll be 11
a.m. tomorrow for the round start time
so the players will have to get up a
little early it's also an earlier
daylight savings time so you know a
little more early that's another hour
but they're gonna have to deal with and
we'll be back here on the YouTube
channel at 1:30 p.m. so be sure to join
us with that said thanks for watching
thanks for having me here filling in for
Ben I had a lot of fun
absolutely tomorrow is gonna be very
exciting as we close out this tournament
and it looks like by June she just
doesn't need to lose and he's our likely
winner in Group B but Group A is pretty
much all up for grabs up for grabs up in
the air all right thanks guys see you
next time
this has been a presentation of the st.
Louis chess club